では始まります よろしくお願いします
一応時間開けましたし
前の話はかなり難しかったんだから
まあもしかするとみんな逃げたと思いますけど
あまり難しい話ですから
じゃあ逃げましょうと
それはごく普通なことで
まあ私たちも話がわからないとあまり聞きたくはないですから
でもそんなに話がわからなくても
そんなに気にすることはないと言いましたから
その内容はそれでね まあそんなに難しいことを話をしているわけじゃないんだから
そんなに心配する必要はないんです
で 今日の話はこのコースの終わり目ですから
一応まとめみたいな感じで
まあもう一回あります
ないでしょ 今日 4回  5回
4回目だね あともう一回あります
5回いやいや 今日 4回目です
そう 幸福と悟りです はい
じゃ あ もう一回ですね
そうです じゃあ  そうするとほんの僅かに難しくなるかもしれません
大体順番で 1つ難しくなる
1つ簡単にしますけど
じゃあ幸福と悟りという
テーマについて それだったら話します
あの その幸福という言葉はこの不思議な言葉で
まあ誰でも目指しているものと言えますね
まあ人間がまあ誰でも幸福になりたいし
動物なんか言ってくれないだけで
もしかすると動物もやっぱり幸福になろうと努力しているでしょうね
で 不幸になろうとはおそらく思わないしね
そこでこの それは一般的なことで
誰でも幸福になりたいならば
我々はやっていること何でも幸福のためでなければいけませんね
ということは  仕事をしたっても
自分の幸福のためであるし
他の研究をなさっても
それは我々の幸福のためにあるし
で 家族はあっても まあ何やってもね
例えば難しいことを スポーツとかね
そういうことをなさってるし
まあそれもいくらかな幸福いくらかではなくて
結構幸福のためにやってるんですね
ですから 世の中誰でも
これは仏教と関係なく
私は言いたいのは みんな幸福というものを探してるんですね
そのために努力しているんです
そこでまあ 現代科学社会というか
現代的なもの この社会も幸福のために作っ
まあ頑張って努力して作ってるんですね
で そのこの我々今この文明なんかはすごく発展しているし
で 現代人として我々はものすごく威張ってるんですね
私たちは大変優れている文化を作っているんだと
科学をものすごく発展しているんだと
いつでも私たちは一番最高なレベルでいると思って
他の歴史やら古いものは考えたりするんですね
そこで発見し 一つ発見しちゃうんですね
こういう風なすごい優れてる文明っていうのは今だけですかと
人間というのはもう進化して
猿からもうどんどん進化して
やっと現代文明を作ったんですか？と
言うと なんかちょっと話合わないところあるでしょ？例えば古代文明というものあるんですね
いろんな古代文明があるんですね
そういうのを研究してみると
なんか私たちはそんなに優れてもの
優れてもの 発展しているかと
一人勝手に自慢できないんではないかなとも思えるんですね
昔でも数学は発展してありましたし
天文学もありましたし
数字もちゃんとありましたし
単に契約社会ありましたし
街なんか今みたいにいい加減ではなくて
ちゃんと計画を立てて街を作ったりありましたし
それはもう 三千年  四千年前の文明を見てもそうであるし
また未だに理解できないものも結構ありましたね
今も見たらなんかもう宇宙との連絡を取っていたんではないかという人々も言うんです
事実はどうかわかりませんだけど
昔々の人々は宇宙とのいろんな生命とのコンタクトを取っていたのではないかと
まあ事実はどうであろうと
私に言えるのは 我々だけは偉く威張ったっても
やっぱり昔の人々も結構文化は発展していたということなんですね
じゃあそれだったら なんでその古代文明がそのまますーっと引き続けて発展しなかったんですかね
例えば三千年の前 四千年の紀元前四千年の前
日本でもそうでしょう
昔々文明がありまして
かなり優れていたんですね
すごい ものすごい優れた文明あったという形跡があるんですね
それは五千年 六千年 もっと前なんですね
今みたいないろんな人から何とか教えてちょうだいとかね
アメリカに頭下げたり
昔は中国に頭に下げたりとかね
なんか惨めな存在でしょ
今は もうまあ誰でもそうなんですけど
まあ日本はまあちょっと前はね
まあ 5世紀 6 4世紀 その時代では中国に頭を下げて下げてとか
現代になってきたら またヨーロッパに頭を下げて下げてとか
現代文化文明を作ってますけど
なんかどこかで惨めな存在ですけど
でも昔はそうでもなかったんですね
なんか誰にも頭を下げていたということも見えませんし
そのまま進んだ方が良かったのにね
インドにしたってもね
エジプトにしたっても
すごい素晴らしい文明あったんだけど
なぜそれはそのまま続けていかなかったんですかね
なんであの文明は壊れたんですかね
それを考えてほしい それで私たちも今安心してはいけないんですね
今すごい優れているんだと
文明も科学も昔のものも崩壊しちゃったんだから
もしかするとちょっとしたことで
今のこの幸福の社会も崩れていく恐れがあるんじゃないかなと
その原因を考えた方がまあわずかにいいかもしれません
あまり役に立たないかもしれませんだけど
それにこの幸福の社会的な立場
今説明しようと私は思ってますけど
この人間が経済的な活動をして優れてる文明文化を作っちゃうんです
なんか古い古いストーリーなんか神話なんかには
この昔の人々の時代のことをわずかに神話的に入ってるんですね
ただ インドの古代文明では
みんなこの飛行機まで作っていたみたいです
ちゃんと鳥の形で作っていたんだと
まあどうせ飛行機だったら鳥の形でなければ飛びませんから
それはもう機械で動くんだと
呪文唱えて人人で動くんじゃなくて
機械で動くんだと ということは
人力で人は足を踏んで動く飛行機ってはないでしょうしね
で それは今神話になっているんですね
ということは その文明は壊しちゃったんですね
インドの皆様 もしかすると聞いたことあると思います
このラーマーヤナ物語という物語あるんですね
ラーマとシータの物語
その物語にあるのは ある文明の破壊の歴史なんです
このインドの人々が行って
ものすごい優れてた文明一つをもう完璧に破壊しちゃったんです
その破壊された側には飛行機まであったんです
破壊したこの今神様だと拝んでるラーマ神様たちが猿なんですね
猿と一緒に行って その人々を破壊する
その人とありとあらゆる力を持っていて
いろんな超能力やら神通力やら
で どうしても壊せ壊れない
倒れない 攻撃できない
それでもその猿の軍隊が行って
そこは破壊したんだ だから猿っていうのは
別に猿には戦争できるわけじゃないんだけど
これ文明としてはちょっと問題の人々で
で 夜叉なんですね 倒した倒れたのは
夜叉っていうのは能力を持ってる
超能力って意味で使っている言葉なんですね
いろんな技を身につけているという意味で
夜叉って夜叉という言葉使っていたんです
遠い遠い昔 現代辞書引いてもその意味が出てこないんです
お釈迦様はちょっと使ってますけど
ヤッチという言葉がありまして
ヤッチという元の言葉があります
ヤッチというのは修行する
訓練する 何か習うという意味なんです
ですから この科学は勉強したっても科学者になりませんね
ちゃんとしたこの実践的なものを習わなくちゃ
ヤッチというのはそこの本質を見ているんですね
このそういうを習った人がヤクシャというんです
これはパーリ語でサンスクリット語だったらこういう風に書くんです
で 薬師様は皆様知ってますね
夜叉という言葉は 鬼だと思ってるんですね
漢字は何の意味もないんです
なんだ 夜の何でしたっけ？こちらの意味は
意味は何ですかね 何の意味もないんです
これは薬師という言葉の当て字ですね
で あの かなり優れていたんです
ある人々なんです 鬼たちじゃないんです
お釈迦様に会って喋ったりしましたから
そこで喋ったものは経で記録しているんです
普通の人間にはもうどうしようも考えられないほど
すっごいレベル高い ものすごい厳密な心の問題とか
存在の問題とか そういうものを聞くんですね
この夜叉といえば 一般的にはなんか文明のない
なんか鬼みたいな もう恐ろしい存在というような感じがあるんですよ
それがこの当時の人々が作った怖いものだと
逃げろと ということで
でも本当に研究してみるとそうでもないんです
すごく優れていた その夜叉の文明をアーリアという人々が壊しちゃったんです
まあアーリアという言葉も一応聞き慣れている言葉でしょうね
間違った アーリアンという
このサンスクリット語でこうやっていますけど
それは民衆 ある民衆なんですね
インドを戦略したのはアーリアンという民族で
アーリア アーリアという民族で
アーリアンというのは複数形で
今のヨーロッパ人もね
コーカシアンの連中もいくらかアーリアンという民族なんですね
だからヒットラーさんが自分がアーリアンですと言って何やったんですかというと
お分かりでしょうね アーリア人が自分が優れていると思っているんですね
まあそこはすごい人間の愚かなところで
もう誰も優れてるわけじゃないでしょうに
別に 他の民族から見ればすごい気持ち悪い考え方です
人間っていうのは自分が優れてると思ってるんですね
モンゴル系の人々は自分が優れてると思っちゃうし
まあそういうコーカシアン系統の人々は自分たちが優れているし
まあどっちにも関係ない私から見ればみんなバカどもでしか何もないんではないか
自分が優れていると自分がひどい目にあうだけですからね
結局は まあそれはそう措いておいて
このアーリアっていう人々のが
この夜叉という文明人を壊しちゃったんです
そのストーリーなんですね
ですから 倒れた側が文明やら科学やら何だかんだもう頂点になっちゃっていて
何も文明も何もない いい加減な猿みたいな人々にやられちゃう
だから猿とちゃんと書いてますから
ハヌマンと言うんですね
ラーマヤナ物語を読んでみると
このハヌマンというのは猿ということで
ラーマ神様が猿と一緒に行ったんです
この戦争に ですから インドヒンドゥー教では猿の神様がいるんですね
で 大変尊敬していて で
ですから 猿という言葉で
やっぱりまあ一応いい加減で
何でも壊したい放題壊すぐらいの
人々で で 野猿たちっていうのはもう飛行機まで持っていたんだだから結構優れていて
そのなんで優れた文明に優れた文明が全然発達していない人々に壊されるんですかね
すごい損なんですね せっかく作った幸福の社会でしょ
いろいろなことを考えるんです
例えば 日本はすごい平和な豊かな国なんですね
もしテロが現れたら どうなるんですかと
ものすごい恐ろしくなっちゃうんですね
全部経済状態はガタガタ倒れちゃうんです
例えばこういう国だから
誰か偉い方々 外国から来る時でも
ちょっと日本ではね ちょっと問題ある場合は
この駅の何て言いますかね
靴かご全部もうシールしておいたりしますね
そこに何か爆弾でも置いておけたらどうかと
そうすると私は考えるのは
この東京の治安を守るために
もしかするとたった一人のテロって
もう日本にはテロはいませんだけど
一人二人の人がちょっとおかしいことをしようとすると
政府側がどれほどお金がかかりますかと計算できます
この東京どこでも警察動かなくちゃいけないんだから
片っ端から調べなくちゃいけないんだから
そう調べたって見つかりますかね
そこでどなたかアメリカの大統領
誰か来る時は 私の部屋にも警察の部屋ではなく
事務所の方にも来るんですね
その時私は考えたのは
もう誰か一人の人が来るだけのことで
一つ一つその区のその区の建物を調べると
調べたって悪いことをしようと思っている人は見つかりくない
隣の喫茶店でも行けばいいんだけど
その時は 見つかりっこない
それでもちょっと問題があったら
膨大なお金がなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから この文明をいろいろ幸福に
経済的に幸福になるのはすごい時間かかるんです
壊そうとすればすぐ壊せるんですね
冗談じゃないんです もしこの国でそういうちょっとした政治的な治安状態がちょっとでも悪くなっちゃったら
もう国の状態というのはもう１年以内でもうガタガタ
もうどうしようもなくなっちゃう
それでこの幸福の弱み
お分かりですかね まあ少々でも
それを昔々ずっと繰り返してきたんです
だから いくら文明が発達しても壊れるんです
例えば現代のね 例えば若者にはちゃんといい加減我々は贅沢させて贅沢させて育てるでしょ
苦労何もさせない 苦労っていうことを何も知らない
それでまあなんで私たちは仕事をしなくちゃいけないんですか？とか
私たちはやりたい放題のことやりますよと思って
もし若い方々はやりたい放題
大のことやっちゃったらどうなるんですかね
こんなこのもう五年かけて作り上げたこの幸福のシステムをもう壊せますよ
一人で もし犯罪でもあっちこっちやりたいほどやっちゃったらどうなるんですかね
すごいもんなんですね
あまりにも発展しているんだから見つかりっこないんです
あの神戸の方はね もう恐ろしい事件があったでしょうに
で 犯人はね 見つかるんですかね
そんな簡単に  これはあまり気にすることはない言葉ですけど
私の勘で言えば見つからないと思いますよ
皆様は怒るかもしれませんし
悔しがるかもしれませんし
私はこれを批判しているんじゃなくて
この世界のシステムよく考えると見つかるのは難しいんですね
ちゃんとした証拠はないし
で みんな犯罪だと思って調べるわけにもいきませんし
もうたった一人ぐらい悪いことしたっても
他の人々はみんな立派な平和を守る立派な人々だからどうしようもないし
それで だから神経質でしょ
みんな警察とそこら辺うろうろしてる
だから別に何の意味もないんですよ
犯罪者っていうのは 今日子供一人殺して
明日も一人殺す 明後日も一人殺す
それはやらないんだから
それほどバカじゃないんだから
もうものすごいバカだったら
次に誰が殺そうと思って見つかりますけど
だから警察の動き方は全く無意味なんですよ
それ一ヶ月とか二ヶ月間ずっといたっても
それでもう犯人知ってるし
ちゃんと自分を守って隠れていて
それでまた忘れたところでまた何かするかもしれません
ですから 一番社会に社会が困った事件っていうのは
犯人を見つかってないんですね
例えばどこかで誰かを殺したとかね
喧嘩してどこかに泥棒に入ったとか
そういうのは社会問題じゃないんです
それはいつでもあることで
奥さんがものすごく腹が立って
旦那さんが浮気するんだからもう殺しちゃったとか
あるいは男もそういう男女の問題で女の人を殺されたとか
そういうのはごく普通な個人レベルで起こる出来事で
もう気にする必要ないんです
すぐ見つかっちゃうし
捕まれるし でも社会問題
例えば森永事件とかね
そういう事件で言われるのは
我々はすごくこの危ない社会にいるということなんですね
あまりにも安心して いくらでも物を売ってますから
何のことなく百パーセント信じて食べる
もし誰かに何かすることはいつでも可能なんです
それはそれで置いておいて
とにかくこのあまりにも我々は発展しすぎて
平和すぎて そういうことからなんか犯人なんか見つからなくなっちゃうし
またそういう社会的などうしようもない犯罪者も出てくるし
もしそういう風にこの法律守らない
常識ない何人か現れちゃったら
いきなり壊れてしまうんですよ
だからその弱みが出てくるんですね
この経済的な豊かさと一緒に
俺 誰のせいでもないんです
それ一応考えてほしいんです
我々もあの 何と言いますか
あの すごい安心した土台の上に歩いてるんじゃなくて
このオンザソードエッジ
いわゆる刀の刃ですか
その上に歩いているんだと
だから別に刀の上に立ったんだからといって足を切れるわけじゃないんです
気をつければ ちょっとでもこうなっちゃったら
体を動かしちゃったらもう切れちゃいますけど
いますね そういう催し物で
まあもうやってる人々は
ですから やっぱり文明っていうのはそういうものなんです
それはもう現代 この地球に作っている文明だけでなくて
昔も同じく壊れたんですね
それなぜ壊れるんですかと
一つはこういう風に このあまりにもできちゃったら
壊すのはとても簡単ということ
今はどんどんお金が使わなくなっちゃって
電子的なコンピューター等で電気信号で金を使おうとしているんですね
もし何かあってコンピューターシステムが壊れちゃったら
みんな貧乏なんですね
もうお金がないと そこで犯罪を起こす場合も
いつもまあ簡単で言えば簡単でもないかもしれませんだけど
昔あったんですね ある人はなんとなくコンピューターである人の口座に数字を打った
そこでお金入れてもないのに
まあ五千万もなんとかとか
もう自分の貯金口座に入ってる
それさっさと下ろしてもらえば
もうそれ まあそれは簡単に見つかりますけど
犯罪誰がやったかということはそれぐらい何か弱いんですね
とにかく 誰かがそういうコンピューター壊しちゃったら
まあお金はどうするんですかというふうにもなっちゃうんですね
だからどんどん我々の社会が電子化になっちゃうでしょ
これからも もし何かあったら
壊れたら もういきなり我々は原始時代に戻る
瞬時に そういうことだから
いくら文明発達しちゃっても壊れるんですよ
で 私は皆様にちょっとした質問したいんだけれど
もし皆様方の一人がこの山の中で迷子になったと
1週間  2週間それで生きていられますかと
獲物を捕まえて何か食べ物
ウサギでも何でも 自分が迷子になって何も道具を持ってない
でも今はフランス料理も作れる作られるし
イタリア料理も作られるし
家のレパートリーもいれば
月曜日フランス語だったら
火曜日は中華料理 水曜日は日本料理
木曜日はインド料理とか
もう毎日ものすごい幸福できてるでしょ
問題なく じゃあどっかの森の中で迷子になったとする
何も持ってないとする
生きて
られますか？フランス料理作れますか？じゃあウサギ 1匹でも取れます？捕めますか？森の中にある食べ物は何か食べてもいいんですか？何が食べていけないか分かります
か？たとえ動物に殺された
まあ何かいたとします
それでもうどうせもう危ないんだから生では食べたくないと
じゃあ火を作れますか？森の中で自分で
作り方知ってますか？まあボーイスカウトとかなんとかあるんだから聞いたことあるかもしれません
だけどやってみるとちょっと違うんですよ
頭で知ることとは 今は火を作ることは全然考えてもないんですね
ガスコンロのスイッチを押せばもうフォーと出ますから
ですから 倒れちゃったら
我々は瞬時に原始時代になっちゃうんです
そういうのはもういつでもこの人類が繰り返しちゃうんですよ
文明 頑張って頑張って
経済的に幸福になる こう 50年
100年  200年頑張って
やっと何か作る そこで 1年で全部壊れると
また頑張って頑張って作ると
また 231年  2年でまた倒れるし
すぐ倒れるんですよ あの神戸でまたわかりますね
地震が起きちゃったら
たった 20 秒で 50 年間の仕事は終わりと
そこでまたさっさと作りましたけど
まあ地震の問題だから
そんなに早く不幸になるわけじゃないんだけど
一応地震がもう 50年ごとに 100年ごとに起きても
地震の側が まあ私にとってはたった 3 秒の仕事をやったように見ているでしょうね
あなた方はじゃあ 100年経って頑張って建物を作ってくださいと
まあ私は 3 秒ですね まだまだ仕事ないなと困っているかもしれませんね
地震の方が ちょっと 1 分
2 分でも頑張らなきゃ倒れないように作ってくれないかとかね
それぐらいなんですね
我々のね できることは
まあそこで じゃあそんな話関係ない話言いますかというと
一つは話を したいんです
で この幸福ということは
そういう道で行ってもそれは幸福かなと
まあちょっと考えた方がいいんです
たとえ私たちはすごく平和で生きていますけど
だからといって我々の子どもたちの時代でもそうなるかどうか分からないし
孫たちの時代でそうなるかどうか分からないし
今も皆様知ってるでしょ
皆様はあれ 何て言いますか
退職金じゃなくてお金もらうでしょ
年取ったら年金 今の人々は年金もらうかないか何か心配でしょうにね
でもどんどんお金がなければ生きていられない時代になっちゃうんですね
ですから 今の年取っている方々は年金なくてもなんとか生きていられるんです
それなりに年金もらっているんです
今 我々の時代ではすごいお金かかっちゃうんですね
それで我々年取っちゃうとさらにお金かかるんですね
その時は年金はもらわないっていうとどうなるでしょうかね
ということはね なんか人間の今の道が幸福の道だと言えますかと
今のやり方は何かどこかでおかしいんじゃないかなとも考えた方がいいんです
でも確かに幸福になりたいんだから
この世にこのように頑張ってます
でも計算してみると危ないし
自分を破壊しているし
我々は自然を破壊しましたし
水を汚したし 大気を汚してしまったし
もう逆戻りはできない
また戻ってほしくれば
我々は全部壊しちゃって
全部爆弾でもかけて全部壊しちゃって
また自然に戻って人間は死ぬしか方法ない
人間死んでもうあるいは原始時代に戻って
300年  400年 あるいは1000年経つと
また大気が水が元に戻るんだから
まあ文明の破壊も無理のない話なんですね
もしかすると当時の人々も自然まで汚染した可能性もあるんです
そうすると世紀末は出てこなきゃダメなんです
それはまあ冗談の話ですけど
まあ一応破壊にならなくちゃいけないしね
まあ結局は私たち苦労していることも確かであって
まあそんな安定した幸福は得られないんですね
そこで仏教とこのちょっと私の話と一般の社会の話が合わないところあるんですね
一般の社会ではとにかく勉強して
とにかくいい仕事を見つけて
いっぱい金を儲けて 家族結婚して
家族を作って まあ食べて
それなりに年取って死ねばいいんじゃないかというぐらいなんですね
まとめればそれぐらいですね
人間の哲学っていうのは
勉強して まあとにかくいい仕事を見つけて
またそれから他の商売なんかやるならば
いっぱい金を儲けて それで家ぐらい一戸二つ作ったりとか
結婚して食べて寝て遊んで死ぬと
で それちょっと考えてください
ちょっと宗教家に対して腹が立つんですね
みんなそういう人々が
あんた方は何言ってるんですかとか
私たちこそものすごくしっかり生きてるんだとかね
でも宗教の立場から見れば
そんなもんかなと 人生っていうのはね
それでそんなもんでもいいんですよ
しっかりしているならば
でもそんなもので作ってる社会っていうのは何人かに壊すことできるんですよ
例えばちょっと悪事やる人々に
まあ例えば若者を4人ぐらい3人ぐらい集めたら
ちょっと脅かすって別に脅しなくてもいいんです
ちょっと脅して もう 10億円でもお金使うように仕向けるできますよ
ちょっとあそこに爆弾かけておきます
ここになんとかしておきますとかね
なんとか何とか何とか何条と言うんですか
あれは九百何とかみたいなものを出しちゃえば
みんなビクビクするし
そこで警察を動くし もういろいろもうそれですごく国のお金がなくなっちゃうでしょうに
見つかりっこはない そういうものを出す人もね
それぐらいの世界ですから
作っているのはね 結局は
それでも我々はこのすごく心の中でビクビクして生きているし
いつでも怖いし なんとか怖いんですね
心配なんです 結構私にこの話して話をしてくれる方々の中で
いろいろ悩んでいると言うんですね
私は悩んでいると言ったって
もう解決法ないんだから
私もあまりもう日本人でもないし
あまり言っていること分からないし
ですから具体的に何に悩んでいるかとおっしゃってくれませんかと
それは初めて考えるんですね
自分が何に悩んでいるんですか
[笑い]って考えてすごく不安があるんだと
じゃあでも私はわかりません
だから何について不安がありますかと
ちょっと教えてくれませんかと
それでまた私は一体何に不安ですか？と考えちゃうんですね
だから不安ですけど 自分が何に不安かもわかってないんですね
そこで言うのは その人によりますよ
答えが若い人だったら将来のこと不安だと
若い時ぐらいのね 将来のことを不安だと
仕事のことを不安だとか
年取っている人 歳の方々だったら健康なことを不安だとかというんですね
それ言った途端 あなたバカではないかと聞きたくなっちゃうんですよ
なぜならば 世の中で安定した仕事とかあるわけないでしょうに
どんな仕事 会社でも倒産するし
国にさえお金がないと言ってるんだから
ですから 別にいいんじゃないですか
それで だからで 例えば自分の仕事はクビになったんだと
リストラで だから出て別に死ぬわけじゃないし
もうどこかで何とかすれば食べてはいられますから
別に いくら日本はもう法律厳しいと言ったっても
例えば自分にはいるところも何もないんだと
仕事もなくなってお金もなくなったんだと
どこかどこにいたっていいんですよ
こんなに法律であんたこっち行ってはいけないと追い出すことはできないんです
いるところなかったらしょうがないでしょうに
例えば土地は自分にはないでしょう
それでお金もない それで国の土地でもいいし
山の中に入って何か植えて
何かね 野菜でも作ったんだからといって
もう警察に捕まるってことはないんです
法律的には違反かもしれませんよ
でもどうやって裁くんですかね
裁けないんです それはお金がある時なんです
皆様にちょっとした収入がある場合は
人の土地に入ってみてください
とんでもないことになりますよ
なります 自分のアパートとか住むところあるのに
どこか公園に夜寝たりしてください
ちゃんと警察が来て捕まって連れて行っちゃうんです
でもホームレスの方々の場合は問題ないでしょ
ですから それはお金がある時なんですよ
仕事がある時なんです
ですから それは誰もわからないもんだから心配する必要ない
それから健康に不安だと言ったっても
この世の中で誰にできますかね
あなたはこれっきりで病気になりませんよと太鼓判を押してくれることはできないでしょうに
だからバカバカしいでしょ
その悩みっていうのは
誰にもできないんだから
とにかく悩んだり不安があったりする
それで私が言うのは せっかくこんな豊かな社会を作っているのに楽しけないんですね
自分がすごく勉強して
しっかり頭が良くて 仕事もできているのに
仕事に行くと近親軽質で不安でもう
イライラしてたりとか
かわいそうなんですね
ちゃんと世界でどんな国と比べたっても
もう一流の収入もらってるのに
なんかどこかで楽しめないというかね
喜びを感じないと そういうことで
幸福って何ですかと考えなくちゃいけないんですよ
これはお金あっても幸福になるわけじゃないんだと
単なる平和があれば それで幸福というものでもないんだと
ただ我々は発展しました
発展しましたと言っただけで幸福じゃないんですよね
すぐ壊れちゃうと で 幸福っていうのは
このお釈迦様から見れば
みんなちょっと分かってないんです
みんなこの幸福っていうのは
もう体を喜ばせることだと思ってるんですね
目で見て 耳で音楽を聴いて
口でおいしいものを食べて
体にはいいベッドやらソファやら
いい建物やらなんとか作ってあげて
いい車があったりしてね
それは体のためでしょ
それで生きてることは幸福だと
で 分かってないのは車買うのはいいんだけど
それは体の楽しみだと理解しないんです
その代わりにどんな車買うかと考える
外車買うか日本車買うかとか
そこでこのお金のある人々はどうせ外車に手を言っちゃうんですね
そこですごいお金なくなっちゃうし
そこでこのすごい高い車買って
どこかへ泊まってから泊まって買い物に行ってくると車がないでしょ
大体 せっかく外車買ったのに誰かに盗まれてるとか
そういうこともない ない
ないことでもないし そこで
そこで車の競争になっちゃうんですね
ベンツがいいか フェラーリがいいかとかと
それでまたどんな型がいいかどうか
どんな色がいいかどうかとか
それで高価なものを買うのはいいんだけど
日本では走れる場所がないし
ね 道路はそんなないんだから
で それでまたストレス溜まっちゃうし
こんなせっかく立派なフェラーリを買ったのに
なかなかもう停めるとこはないとかね
で この車を持ってアメリカに行くんですかね
それまた意味がないし
で そこで結局いいものを買ったのに
必要な喜びを感じなくなっちゃうんですね
それは体のために買うんだとわかったら
自分の体には車買うんですよ
自分の体に気持ちよく行ける車を買う
それ以上のものはしない
それ自分の足になるんですね
車って そうすると愛情が生まれてくるんでしょうね
自分ではちゃんとコントロールできるし
自分の足になってるし
なんか居心地が良くて
今の車っていうのはいろんなこのカラクリみたいなものいっぱい入ってるんですね
何ももうこれなんだかあれなんです
やっぱりわからないんですね
ですから もう車は動いてはいるんだけど
ほとんど使ってない いろんな機能がいっぱいあるんだから
ちょっと故障しちゃったら修理できないし
だから使わない機能はあっても愛情が生まれてこないし
ですから これは体のために買うんだと思ったら
もう自分にすごい愛情が生まれる車が買える
で 車に愛情が生まれちゃったら
それを洗うのは楽しいし
乗ってどこか行くのは楽しいし
何かちょっとトラブル起こしちゃったら
まあなんかそれもうね
それなりにもう自分知ってるんだから
内容はね 修理頼んだっても
ここら辺こういう問題ですからね
直してくれと言えるし
結構楽しいんですよ それは見えで買っちゃうと全部楽しさが消えちゃう
それから恐ろしさ出てくる
建物を買う場合も同じなんですね
単なるデザインやらいろんなことでいくんじゃなくて
あ これは家族みんな楽しく過ごすために
体のために みんなお互いに仲良く楽しくするために買うものやと思っちゃうと
単なるマイホーム買おうマイホーム買おうということにならない
たまにマイホーム買うんだけど
通勤距離は 2時間とかね
で それで子供もまた同じ家族は顔を合わせなくなっちゃうんですね
奥さんに出ても 遠いところにいても大変難しくね
生活が難しくなったりしてね
そういうのはあまり意味がない
自分の家が何のために必要でしょうかねとか考えて
本当に困ってるんですかね
自分には自分の家っていうものはないんだからと考えて
やっぱり困ってるんだと思ったならば買う
さっさと 自分の家がなくたって別に困ることはないなとわかったら
別にそこまではする必要はないし
そういうふうなことないでしょ
現代我々の時代ではとにかくこの宣伝社会だから
とにかく宣伝して もう何て言いますか
洗脳されちゃうし つい買ってしまっちゃうし
一番いいのは 勉強になるのはこのテレビ
通信テレビで物を売ってるこの番組ありますね
あれ 何と言いますか テレビショッピングとか何とかとかね
ああいうのはもう欠かさずに見てください
どれほど人を馬鹿にしようと思ってるんですかと
で まあそれは向こうは商売だからね
とにかくそういう洗脳して買わせよう買わせようと
ですから ここでそういうことで幸福は得られないというのは私たちの言い方なんです
ですから 幸福論を考えてみましょうと
人間が眼耳鼻舌身という五つが人間にあります
眼 目 それから耳 鼻 舌 体と５つあるんです
その５つを刺激するんです
目を刺激する いろんな綺麗なものを見せ
見せてあげて 耳に音を聞かせてあげて
刺激 刺激してあげる 耳に音
音楽とかね それで鼻には香りを上げて刺激させる
口に美味しい味を味わわせてあげて刺激する
体にいろいろいい感触をしてあげて刺激してあげる
それなんです 人間の人生っていうのは
その刺激を求めて生きているんですね
その中に頭で考えちゃうんだから
ちょっと間違う間違いがあるんです
考えるでしょ 何か見栄やら嫉妬
高慢とか何とか出てきて
せっかくあの人より私がやらなくちゃいけないとかなっちゃうんですね
そうすると結局体を刺激することもできなくなっちゃうんです
例えば 自分の体にこの食べ物はおいしいと感じるかもしれませんだけど
今流行っているのはなんとか食べ物だから
これ食べなきゃ時代遅れだぞ
それやったりする 食べたりする
そういうおいしくもないのに
このもうすごい良い食べ物やと人気あるものは食べたりするんじゃないんですかね
自分にはあまり好きでもないのに
その時代で流行っている色やら服やら着たりとかね
をします そういうところでちょっとずれちゃうんですね
幸福の概念が まあとにかく我々はこの眼耳鼻舌身というこの５つを刺激するために生きてるんだから
適当に刺激あればいいんじゃないかなと
適当に美しいものを見て
だからといって もう見たい放題追っていくと不幸になる
適当に音楽を聴いて楽しむ
でも時間聴いちゃうと
それは苦になっちゃうんです
苦しみになってひどい目に遭う
適当に味わうことはいいんです
だからってグルメになってしまっちゃったら病気になってしまうんです
美味しいものしか食べませんよと思っちゃったら
頭も悪くなっちゃうし
病気にもなるし 早く死んでしまっちゃうし
体のことも同じなんです
適当に体楽しめばいいんですよ
それ体楽しむこと 肉体的な楽しみいっぱいいっぱいに集中的にやっちゃうと
ありとあらゆる社会問題が生まれてくる
いろんな問題が だから適当にいいんです
適当 この量を超えちゃったら
そこに苦しみがあるんです
[背景音楽]食べるのは楽しいんですよ
気持ちいいんです でもそれは量のいないんですね
量を超えちゃったら もうかなり苦しみを味わわなくちゃいけない
音楽でもある短い時間
気持ちよく落ち着いて聴くと結構楽しいでしょ
それでいつまでもヘッドフォンつけちゃって聴いてると
あれでは楽しくないと思いますよ
かなり本人がわかってないんだけど
かなり精神的に肉体的に苦労していると思います
ですから せっかくの幸福だから
なんで無駄にするかわからないんですね
せっかく耳を持って生まれたんだから
それなんで耳が遠くなるほど音楽を聴いて苦労感じるんですかね
脳細胞死ぬんだから あまりにも音楽長い時間聴いちゃうと難聴になっちゃうんです
そうすると障害でもって生まれてもないのに障害者になるでしょうに
ただ美味しいものを食べればいいんだけど
ただそればっかり美味しいものばっかり選んだりして
トマトを食べる時も僕は見てるんです
あれはお湯に入れて また水に入れて皮まで剥いて
まあ食べやすくするこのやり方
そのまま食べればいいのに
そうすると結局卵から得られる栄養も体に入らないし
それまた油で炒めるわ
いろんなことをするわ
結局美味しい食べ物を作って毒にして食べると
あの まああまりこの日本の天ぷらとか体に悪いわけじゃないんだけど
例えばエビっていうのは体にいいものですけど
それは天ぷらにして食べると
年取ってる人々にとってはあんまりいいものじゃないでしょうに
結局エビを買って じゃあこれ食べたら体にいいんだから
じゃあ毒にしましょうと
毒にしてそれ食べると
だからそこまで まあ天ぷら別に私はこの
まあちょっと例だけで
あまり気にする必要ないんですけど
で あの 単なるこの美味しさばっかり追っかけちゃうと
せっかく死ぬまで美味しくご飯食べて幸福でいられることはできなくなっちゃうんです
それでかわいそうじゃないかなと
ですから お釈迦様は決して喜ぶな
楽しむなとは言ったことがないんです
一般の方々は智慧 知識
智慧を持って合理的に程を見て人生楽しみなさいと
家族と仲良く 子供と仲良く
社会と仲良く 自分の健康を守りなさいと
それをちゃんと教えてるんです
それも幸福なんです なんかまあ誤解しているような感じがしますよ
仏教っていうのはあの世の教えだよと
なぜならば 私たち見たっても神の系譜と違う生活をしているんだから
あの日本で出家する人方々はなんかテレビでもよく言うんですね
仏道っていうのは それは死ぬことと同じですよと
社会捨てることですよと
僕はあのテレビの出家番であなた死んでくれてくれた方がありがたいですよと思っちゃいますよ
みんなに迷惑だよと そんな悲観的なことをおっしゃってるわけじゃないんで
その人は何か問題があって出家したって
それはその人の問題で
他の人にそんなこと関係ないでしょうに
みんなに出家しろとかね
ああだこうだ そんな暗い話は言ってないんです
馬鹿をするなと言ってるんです
やりすぎるなと お金儲けるのはいいんだけど
だからといってやり過ぎはやめなさいと
結局全部失いますよと
ご飯食べるのはいいんだけど
やり過ぎはやめなさいと
もう二度と食べられなくなりますよと
それは事実でもあるし
私たちはすらすらこの欲に引き摺られて
つい食べると つい遊ぶと
つい余計なことを見てしまうと
まあちょっとだけいいんじゃないかと
そのちょっとだけ問題になるでしょうね
この若い人々はね まあ一回だけが味を試し
試しに麻薬使っても ちょっと一回だけだからとやっちゃうでしょ
一回で終わりますか？それで人生終わっちゃうんです
一回で麻薬終わるんじゃなくて
人生まで終わってしまっちゃうんです
そこら辺気をつけなさいっていうのは
それ嫌味じゃないんです
それこそ我々のためを思って
我々の幸福を思って言うことなんです
ですから 幸福の概念というのは小欲知足なんです
小欲ですか 小欲知足なんです
足は足りるですね 知は知る
ですか そこで問題は我々の心にあるんですね
これは認めたくない でしょ
正直に言えば いや 頭ではわかってますよ
私もわかってます 頭では
でも心では認めたくないんですね
次 次もうもうちょっと欲を出してみるでしょ
お金が入っちゃうと もうちょっと欲を出して
例えばこの女性の方々はいくらか自分の老後のためにお金が貯まってくるでしょ
そうすると誰かがうちに来て
若い人が来て すごくもうなれなれしく喋ったりして
もうもうどうせうちに寂しくいるんだから
すごい金儲かる話でありますよとかなんとか言っちゃうと
なんか愛情が生まれてきて
相手に対してこちらもう年上であるし
優しくなっちゃって その人を信頼して
じゃあ頼みますよと せっかく自分の老後のためのお金を頼んだところで
もうそれっきりで終わりと
もう人のどんな人かわからなくなっちゃうしね
そういう事件 いつでも世の中で常にあるんですね
ですから この私たちはほんのわずかに欲出しちゃうんです
このほんのわずかで事故起こしちゃうんです
それで幸福がなくなっちゃうんです
だからこれ いくら安全運転していても
ほんのわずかに居眠りしちゃったら危ないでしょ？いくら言い訳していても
ほんの僅かに居眠りだからいいんじゃないかといったってもうもうこちらはもうぶつかってるんだから
で なぜ仏教 あるいは宗教必要かというと
こういうことで小欲小欲知足は人間誰であろうか
いくらかはわかってます
問題は心で認めたくないこと
そこは学校で教えてくれない
会社で教えてくれない
逆を教えてくれるんです
金儲けろと 学校でももう欲ばっかり作ろうと言ってるんです
戦い勝ちなさい よく勉強しろと
よくもう点数ですか 出しなさいとか
だから学校も会社も社会も
人はいかに不幸にするかということしか考えてないんです
ですから 宗教の世界で小欲知足のことを教えてあげなくちゃいけない
でも教えただけでは聞いてくれないね
これ 我々の心の問題なんです
ですから いくらか心の状態を直してみる
心の底から小欲知足の人間になるようにする
それが宗教なんです ですから
この経済活動をしながら
政治活動をしながら 皆様に２本の足なければ歩けないでしょう
今は１本の足で歩いているので
トントントントンと飛んで飛んで
だからいつ倒れるかわからないんです １
本の足で歩くんだから
もう２本の足必要なんです
それはいわゆる宗教なんです
宗教っていったって あの世の話やら天国の話やら
神通力の話とか 超能力の話なんか
そんなこと役に立たない
この小欲知足を実践できるように心を作ってくることは必要なんです
そうすると足２本も空いてるんです
経済活動いくらしたっても倒産のおそれがない
いくら音楽を聴いても難聴のおそれがないと
いくら美味しいご飯を食べても
もう栄養取りすぎとか糖尿病とかなんとかはないんだと
健康的になるんだというふうになる
幸福は長く細く長く味わえるんです
ですから この幸福の我々に必要な 1番目の幸福っていうのは
この小欲知足をできるような心を作ることなんです
それはどうやって作りますかと
いろいろ方法はあるんです
どうやれば小欲知足の人間になるんでしょうかと
どうやればなるんですかね
やっぱり まあわかりやすく言えば
やっぱりこの まずこの
あまり欲を出しちゃったら危険だと
いろいろこの その恐怖感を考える
欲を出すこと もう足ることを知らないことの恐ろしさ
いわゆる世の中に目を開けておく
野村事件が起こるは いろんなことを世の中で起こる
毎日よく勉強になるでしょうに
毎日何かありますよ 勉強になることは
誰かがもう失敗する人はいるんだから
人生 だからそれはその方々はまあ一時的には成功していたんだけど
まあ完全に失敗している
なぜ失敗したかというと
これでしょうね あ なるほどと
そういうふうに理解する
例えば いろいろお金が欲しくて
なんとかいけないことをしちゃったら
バレちゃったら大変な目に遭うでしょうに
バレなくたってもビクビクして生活しなくちゃいけないし
この秘密のある人生というのはいかに不安かとは
この それも感じる それはこのパーリ語でこういう言葉があります
なかなかこの日本語のあるかどうか忘れませんけれど
ヒビというんです これはオッタッパというわけです
あのヒビというのは  ちょっと恥じるということなんですね
恥ずかしくというような意味なんですね
いわゆる恥ずかしいという意味でもなくんだけど
何か自分を態度を持って考えるんですよ
自分のこと せっかく自分のことだから態度を持って考えて
この汚いこと 醜いこと
品のないこと 悪いことを私だったらしませんと
いわゆるすごく立派な態度を持つことなんです
けしからんなことはいけないことをもうなんかわいわいとやっちゃうでしょうに
そうじゃなくて 別にお釈迦様は人間というのは素晴らしいんだと言ってるんだから
せっかく人間に生まれたんだから
猿ではないんだからね
犬猫でもないんだから
人間だから 人間らしく態度を持って
他の人はこういうことをやるかもしれませんだけど
私はやりませんと 他の人はちょっとお金ごまかすかもしれませんだけど
私はごまかしませんと
他の人は人を裏切るかもしれませんだけど
私はやりませんと それは私個人の生き方だと
私は態度を持って生きているんだと
そういう素晴らしい態度
余計な態度ではなくて
自分を守る態度 それを育てようと
オッタッパっていうのは恐怖感なんです
でも怖い恐怖という意味でもないんです
それはこの本当に怖いと感じてほしいんです
何が怖いと感じてほしいですかと
悪いことをすること いけないことをすること
法律を犯すこと それが怖いんだと
恥ずかしいんだと この怖いものを知らない人生は良くないんです
よく怖いものを知った方がいいんです
その二つで我々の社会も守られるし
社会の幸福も守られるし
人間に長く幸福を感じることができるんです
ですから これから仏教的な解釈をしますけど
義理というのは悪いことをしないよう
しません しないように心に出てくる自分の立場を考えて
私のようなものはこんなけしからんことをしませんというふうに思って悪いことをやめる
おたっぱっていうのは
私のようなものはそんなことをしたら
どんな罰が罰が社会から与えられるんでしょうかと
この罰のこと怖いと ひどい目には遭いたくないんだと
痛い目にも遭いたくないんだと
自分のことを考えて悪いことをやめると
その二つを頭に入れておくと
小欲知食を実現できます
実行できます たとえ食べ過ぎになる時でも
これは怖いんだと なんで私はもうバクバク食べるんですか？恥ずかしいんじゃないかと
まあ適当な量を食べた方が自分の素晴らしい人間だと
品格のある人だと自分を
もうそういう態度を持つ
あるんだからって言って食べるんじゃないとかね
パーティーだからといっても
もう食べるんじゃないんですよと
たまに失敗するでしょ
自分の家では一応コントロールして食べたりするんだけど
それがパーティーに行っちゃったところで食べてしまっちゃうとかね
その時は客観的に見れば恥ずかしいでしょうにね
いっぱい皿にいろんな食べ物をいっぱい入れて
食べるわ食べるわ それよりはほんの少々の僅かな量を入れて
まあほんの食べて それで家に戻って
またあのパーティーでかっこつけて食べなかったんだから
ラーメンでも食べよう
そういうことはまた良くないんです
じゃなくて やっぱり自分がそれなりにしっかりした生活をちゃんと
8時半まで  8時までしっかりと生きてるんだと
自分の態度を持って そうすると一人でもいる時でも食べ過ぎにならない
それで恐怖感でもいいんですよ
食べ過ぎの場合は こんなこと食べちゃったら体中脂肪溜まっちゃうんではないかとか
高血圧になるんじゃないか
コレステロール溜まるんじゃないかと
それでまあね 心臓とかね
そういうところで血管が固まっちゃったらどうなるんでしょうね
脳出血したらどうなるんですか？とかね
そこをちゃんと考えて
自分が脳出血して もうもう倒れてる状態
それでみんなにもう面倒見てもらわなくちゃいけないし
そんな怖いでしょうに
そう考えちゃうと じゃあ怖いんだったら
今からもちゃんと食事をコントロールすると
さっさとご飯にも塩をかけるでしょうに
私は本当に怖いんですよ
みんなもうお醤油使うわ
塩かけるわ もうもう何食べても塩
塩 塩 世界で一番健康な人
あるのは日本なのに健康に悪いんです
塩か油かどっちかにやってるんだから
だからそこは別にそんなに塩を食べなくたってもいいんじゃないかとかね
それよりは脳出血は危ないんだと
思って恐怖感感じちゃうと
また余計に塩を取らずに済むし
自分が薄味食べるんだと非理を持っては食べ物は薄味の方がいいやと
自然の味でいいんじゃないかと思ったら非で自分を守られる
それは他のことでも会社の場合も同じなんです
恥ずかしいことはしませんと
怖いことは絶対しませんと
例えば仕事をしっぽかすと
なんとなく自分のプライドが傷つくでしょ
ですから バリバリと仕事をする
私のような者は なんで仕事をいい加減にせなくちゃいけないのに
やることはしっかりやります
だからといって この場合はこれぐらいお金はいろいろ資料ごまかしちゃうと貰えますと思っても
やっぱりこれは危ないと
こんなことやっちゃったらと
せっかく自分の真面目に頑張って苦労して仕事したのに
それ全部なくなっちゃうんだと
ですからやりませんと
人に誘惑されてもやりましょう
やりましょうと 麻薬使いましょう
使いましょうと誘惑されてもやらないんだと
これは個人的なことを言ってはいけないんですけど
私は小さい時が我々は男の子だから
どうせ裏で悪いことをしたいんですね
悪いことというのは いろんなこのまあいたずらなんかはしたがっちゃうんですね
それはすごい刺激的であるし
男たちには誰かに何とか言うことやらね
なんとかいたずらすることっていうのはね
で 母がこれはどうせどんな母でもね
子供を男の子がいると結構もう心配だからね
で いろんなちょっとした工夫したんですね
自分の場合は 最初からもうこの尻取った布を作ってくれたんです
他の子供たちが悪いことしちゃうと
まあお前なんかはね そんなにもう自分の家の人々はね
恥ずかしくなることをしないでしょうとかね
プライドつけてくれるんですね
この子はもう我々の家柄のしきたり
ちゃんと守ってくれて
何のしきたりかあんまりわからないんだけどね
こんな親を恥ずかしくすることは全然しませんねとか
別にやったことでもないし
そんなやる前もってここでも釘を押す
今はわかるんだけどね
これ前もって釘を押してるっていうことだと
そうすると この学校に行ったり
この子供たちと遊んだりすると
いろんなことをやろうやろうと言うんですね
言うと僕はこんなことやっちゃったら
もう父が怒るかもしれませんし
母がすごい恥ずかしくなるかもしれませんし
例えば誰かのうちのいろんな向こうは村だからね
別に人みんな土地持ってるし
自分の土地塀がないんだからどこでも歩けるんですね
ですから どんな家でも家の家ではなくて
庭の果物を取ったっても構いませんだけど
それは知ってもしけないんだと
でもいけないんだからやりたくなっちゃうんです
なぜかというと この家の人が何やってる？追っかけてくるでしょ
そうするとこの逃げるのが楽しくて
で 人のものを取ったりする
で 見つかっちゃったらもう逃げるんですね
これセーフだと 逃げたんだと
それ刺激で でも私は一度もやったことがないんです
で 他の子とやっちゃって
すごい これはいくらなんでも泥棒ではないかと
それで逃げたって もし見つかったら
その人は自分の家は知ってるし
同じ村でその人は母親に言うだろう
そうすると自分の子供は泥棒したんだと思ったら
母親としては本当にもう恥ずかしくて
もう面子が立たないんではないかと
やっぱりそんな汚いことは恥ずかしいことやったらいかんと
私はやりませんだからと平気で言うんです
あなた方やりなさいと
そういう風にこの前もってこの非理取ったと押さえておっちゃうんだから
もう何のことなく悪いことはしないというか
できないというかね ですから
この仏教の国ではよく使うことで
日本の文化でも仏教文化にある言葉ですけど
その言葉は ですから 我々今までなかったならば
態度とかこれから作ってみましょう
今まで怖いものを知らなくて
どんなことをやったならば
これからはやっぱり怖いものは怖い
やめますと 我々は立派な人間だから
プライドを持ちますよと行動すると
この小欲知足を守られるし
それによって長い時間幸福を味わえる
そこで次の幸福の定義はこの充実感なんですね
[背景音]別にお金あるんだから幸福ということがないんです
マイホームあるんだから幸福ということでもないし
いい会社に仕事をしているんだからといって幸福になるわけじゃないんです
人間にはやっぱりこのやること
自分がすることにからなんとか充実感がないと
それだけなんです ポイントは
充実感がないと ものすごい生きることが辛いんです
そういうことで 我々はこの金集まること
権力集まること そのゴミ拾うことは幸福じゃないんだ
それはゴミなんです いくら土地を買っても死ぬ時は置いていくんだから
いくら美味しいものを食べたって
体自体もゴミですから
別に捨てるもんだから
捨てるものはゴミで 持っていくものは財産で
死ぬ時は何を持ってきますか？まあ
仏教の人に聞いたら 自分のいい行い持っていきますよと今答えますけど
自分がやったいい行いと悪い行いしか持っていけませんと
他のものは全部捨てていくんだというのが仏教の答えなんです
死ぬ時は まあ財産は持っていく
ゴミは捨てる じゃあ我々何を捨てますか？家も捨てる
財産も捨てる 体も捨てる
全部ゴミなんです だから一生懸命ゴミばっかり拾う
いくら運動したっても年取りますし
いくら健康食品を食べても体が病気になるし
いくらお化粧したっても
年取っても皮膚が老化するし
それで でも悔しいのは死ぬ時は捨てなくちゃいけないし
持っていくのは自分がどのように生きてきたんですかという結果だけなんです
心は清らかでいたか 心は汚れていたかということだけですから
捨てるのはゴミだから
我々今ゴミばっかり集めてるでしょうに
だから我々いうのは そのゴミばっかり集めることにもう全部専念するんじゃなくて
充実感感じてみた方がいいんです
ただ金儲けたんだから幸福ではありません
ただ健康だからといって幸福ではありません
家庭安全だからって そればっかりでは幸福ではありません
子供がいるんだからといって幸福ではありません
子供がいないんだからといって幸福ではありません
今 現代ではね 女性はいるんですね
結婚はしないとかね その方々の幸福は結婚しないことですけど
結婚しないんだから幸福というどこに書いてますか？そうでもないし
だからって結婚することは幸福だとどこかに書いてますか？そうでもない
そんなものは幸福でも不幸でもどっちにでも入りますよ
結婚して成功すれば幸福であって
失敗しちゃったら大不幸であって
まあ独身主義もいい 独身人生もいいんだけど
もう仕事があって収入があって
すごい体力があって健康な時はいいんだけど
年取ってくるとまたどうかなと
わかりますけどわかりませんけど
そんなものは幸福でもなんでもないんです
単なる生き方 幸福っていうのは日々の充実感
ですから 2番目の幸福は何ですか？日々の充実感
なんとかしなくちゃいけない
今からそれを頑張ってみてください
確実に幸福になるんです
というすごい簡単なんです
自分がやることを何でもいいのでしっかりやればいいんです
なんでこんなことやらなくちゃいけない
なんてこと もうそんなこと考える必要ないんです
で よく考えて 私は今の時間はこういうことをしなくちゃいけない
それだけ それはしっかりとやる
例えば今勉強することだから
私の話を聞く時間だから
まあとにかく話はもうそんな大した話ではないかもしれませんだけど
とにかく真面目に聞きましょうと
そうすると たとえ私の話
くだらない話であっても
よく聞きましたという充実感が生まれるんです
無駄になかったと あの時間は
食事するときでも しっかりと味わってよく食べると
そうするとよく食べたという充実感が生まれるんです
子供でもいて 子供と遊ぶときはもう思い存分遊ぶと
あ 仕事に行かせてあれしなくちゃとか
ご飯炊かなくちゃ もう夜のおかずも買わなくちゃとか
もうイライラしながら子供と遊んじゃいますから
どっちにもないでしょうに
結局充実感がなくて ストレス溜まって不幸で
だから皆様もすごい損しているんですよ
せっかくお金もあるのに
素晴らしい国で生まれたのに
平和な国であるのに もう経済的に何も問題ないのに
健康の問題ないのに 不幸ばっかしで
それはもう損ばっかしでね
もし貧しい国だったら
まあ一応いくらか許してあげてもいいんだけどね
ですから 我々はあまりにも忙しくて
せっかくの幸福を味わえない
ですから すごい気持ちよく
気楽に子供と遊ぶ時はもう思い存分遊ぶ
その時間で もう買い物の時間になったら
じゃあ今から買い物の時間だよと
じゃあお母さん買い物行きましょうと行けばいいし
そこで買い物に行くときは
他のことを考えるんじゃなくて
店の品物をきちんと見て
何が何が何があるんですか？とかね
そうするとしっかり買い物できるし
ああ 今日はいい買い物できたと
料理作る時はきちんと
まあこうやってこうやってしましょうとやって
それきちんと料理もできるし
そうすると この余計なことを考えると
この充実感がなくなっちゃうんです
なんで私はこんなことしなくちゃいけないんですかとか
一体私のせっかくの人生はこんなもう家事
家事と なんて言いますか
家事 洗濯 そればっかしにもう年取ってしまうんではないかとか
そういうのはもう正真正銘の不幸の塊なんです
決して現代的でもう飛んでるわけじゃないんです
なぜならば もう何も得られないんです
そういう人々は きちんと仕事をする人には何でもできるんですよ
私はこの大学にいた時はすごく楽しかった
一つことはあって この結構年取っているおばあちゃんたちが大学にまた入って勉強していたんです
あれ見て素晴らしいやと
やっぱり日本というのは幸福な国だと思ったんです
なぜかというと まあ自分が子供育てて
子供大きくなって 子供から解脱しましたし
で もう家でご飯食べて寝る
寝るのはもうあれだから
もう一応勉強でもしましょうと
だからといってくだらない勉強じゃなくて
しっかり大学に入って勉強しましょうと
それでまたもう余計なものを勉強しても意味がないんだから
じゃあ哲学やら宗教やら勉強しようではないかといって
宗教哲学やら仏教哲学
そういうものを勉強する
仏教哲学なんかっていうのは男の世界なんで
ものすごい難しいんだから
あれにおばあちゃんたちが入っていて
勉強やっちゃうと 本当に素晴らしい素晴らしいとしか言うことがないんですよ
でも自分たちもまあ若い人々と別に一緒に勉強できないかもしれませんだけど
それに負けずにもう頑張りますから
ですから 勉強自体は別にうまくいったといかなくていいんですよ
あれでもいいことにチャレンジする
大学の雰囲気を楽しむ
いろいろテキストを読んでそれを楽しむ
そこで必死になって研究して
レポート書いてそれを楽しむと
そういう方々はまあ本当に幸福なんです
ですから 家の仕事をよくできたんだから
それできるでしょ 私がなんで子供のために人生を犠牲にしなくちゃいけないやと思う人
お母さんが子供の面倒を見てないんだから
もう死ぬまで子供を追っかけていかなくちゃいけないんですよ
何やるかわからないんだから
子供たちが ですから 子供育ててる時はしっかりと育てちゃえば
もう早く卒業できるんですよ
早く解脱できるんです
だから私が言うのは どんなことをしたっても
たとえ掃除にしたっても
たとえちょっとしたタオルを畳むことにしたっても
それ充実感味わってやっちゃったら
その時間は幸福であって儲かっちゃうんです
悩んではいけません 瞬間でも
で 僕はそれもっと大胆に言うんですよ
たとえ自分の家が火事になっても
なんで泣くんですかと
損でしょうに 泣くことは
家が火事になったのは別にまあやむを得ず損ですけど
その上に泣いたり悩んだりして病気になったりして
もっと損する必要ないでしょ
家が火事になったよとね
発狂でもして まあなんか今日はどこに寝ればいいかなとね
明るく考えれば ものすごい充実感があるんです
そこで 別にその道が正しいでしょ
どこかに行って夜寝る時はね
どうしようどうしよう
せっかく夜寝られないとかね
そうじゃなくて 他の人から見ても
本当にあなたの家が火事になったんですかと
嘘ではないかと言われるほど明るくなければいけませんよ
人生は 別にお金もかかりませんしね
明るくなるために お釈迦様はそういう風に
いつでも楽しく生きてなさいと
楽しく生きるっていうのは
馬鹿楽しいじゃなくて
物事をちゃんと見て 充実感があって
しっかり仕事をすることから生まれる楽しみ
酒飲んでふざけてる楽しみだっていうのは
地獄の苦しみだと言うんです
麻薬を取って ああ楽しい楽しいとか
あっちこっち女の人と遊んだりして
男た男たちの楽しみっていうのは
自分で自分の首を吊ってることだと
それはその通りでしょうに
そんな楽しみを仏教では決して認めてない
賭け事 酒 麻薬 不倫 浮気
それはもう地獄の入り口だと
この地獄っていうのは
あの世の地獄よりこの世の地獄でもありますよ
その代わりに私が言うのは
努力 精進 汗流してちゃんと仕事をする
正直であること 借金しないこと
信頼できる人間になること
嘘をつけないこと どんな社会でも
どんな偉い人々のところでも
堂々と胸張って行けるような人格あることとか
そういうふうになってくださいと
それは幸福の道であると
じゃあ反対できますか
その意見に 人間であればあるほど反対できませんと思いますよ
どんな社会にしたっても
胸を張って生きるぐらい自分がしっかりした性格であるならばすごいでしょうに
自分が人に信頼できる人間であるならば
嘘をつかない 騙しはしない
すごい態度を持って生活する
いかなることがあっても
殺されてても 自分が悪いことをしないというと
みんなすごい人だと尊敬するでしょうに
そういうことから いつでもニコニコと生活しなさいと
怠けるなと はっきりと言うんですよ
朝早く起きなさいと 朝太陽が出て
みんな鳥たちがもう仕事してるのに
朝寝坊する連中はもう不幸になるんだと
それは当時の文化でね
当時はもう農業文化だから
どうせ太陽より先にニワトリと一緒に起きなくちゃいけないんですね
今の社会システムは違いますから
まあ夜仕事をする人は10時まで寝たっても
それは別に構いませんだけど
その場合は言うのは寝過ぎダメですよとということなんです
ですから 釈尊の幸福の道っていうのは
この世の中でどんな人間にも違いますよと言えるものじゃないんです
それから 宗教信仰と関係なく守られるし
そういうふうに幸福を探すということは仏教の教えであります
その幸福はすごい具体的で合理的で
そうすると宗教だから
あのようなことをどうしますかという問題が出てきます
どうせ仏教でいうのは
あなたの行いがあなたの来世を決めますよと
じゃあ今私がおっしゃったような生き方だったら
行いが悪いんですか？嘘はつかない
人騙しはしない 悪いことはいかなる理由であっても悪いことはしない
浮気もしない 不倫もしない
賭け事もしないとか 麻薬やらアルコールやらそんなものに依存しないとか
しっかり仕事をするんだと
家族の面倒をちゃんと見るんだ
社会の面倒をちゃんと見るんだ
そういういっぱい教えがあるんです
それを行いが悪いと言えますかね
そんなことで それは素晴らしい行いでしょうに
ですから そういう人が亡くなったところで
たとえ皆様が信仰している絶対的な神様がいるならば
その神様がそのこの人を地獄に落としたくたっても落とせないんです
その代わりに神が地獄に落ちるかもしれません
なぜならば この人しっかりしているんだから
じゃああなたが地獄に行ってください
私が天国に行くんだよと
日本に物語あるんですよ
このあの このしっかりすることはどれほどありがたいかと
あるこのおばあちゃんがいて
このみんな仏様を拝んでるんだから
そのおばあちゃんがこの鬼を拝んでるんですだと
いいおばあちゃんだ 私もストーリー読み始めたら
すぐいいおばあちゃんだなと
みんな仏様を拝んでどうか成仏できませんと
このおばあちゃんがみんな私鬼を拝むんだと
鬼とは地獄の生き物だから鬼を拝んでるんだと
みんないいことしてる中
何もいいことしませんだと
地獄に落ちちゃったんですね
落ちたら 閻魔さんがあんた何かいいことしたんですかと
全然してないよと それで念仏でも唱えたんです
念仏なんかクソくらえ
誰が唱えるんだそんなことは
と言うんだそう そこで地獄に行ったら
地獄の鬼たちが あのばあちゃんがすごい私たちのことをよく心配してくれたんだと
毎日我々のことをよく思っていたんだからね
言って いつでも優先に何でもしてくれるんだそうです
地獄で みんなもう並んでいると
いろいろいじめられて
おばあちゃんもう先に行ってくださいと
そこでもう閻魔さんがもう聞いたら
もう何もいいことしてないんだから
で そこでこの じゃああなたの歯を抜くんだと言ったら
おばあちゃんがもう抜く
ああ それは良かったって言うんですね
歯を抜くんですか？それは良かったと
で 閻魔さんがこの人はなんとかもうきゃあと痛みで悩まさなくちゃ
地獄だから苦しめなくちゃいけないんだと言って
鬼たちにこのおばあちゃんにも歯を抜きなさいと
そしたら鬼ちゃん おばあちゃんこっちいらっしゃいと
ちゃんと座らせて じゃあ口開けてとか言って見たら
虫歯があるんですね で
鬼たちが虫歯を引っ張って抜いたんだそうで
でおばあちゃんが良かった良かった
君たちが私は本当にこれ痛くて痛くて虫歯が
で笑ってるんです そこで閻魔さんがまた困っちゃう
歯を抜いたって なんであの人泣かないんですかと
いろいろそういうことがあって
最後にこの針の山を登るようにしちゃったんですね
それが一番厳しいことで
で 鬼たちが仕事中だから
まあおばあちゃんにこの針の山を登ってくださいと言ってますよと
言ったら まあ自分の袋に何か装置があって
鉄で作っている おばあちゃん
これつけて行ってくださいと
その方が登れるんだと
他の人々はなかなか登れなくて毎日苦しんでるんだと
そしたらおばあちゃんが何のことなく
もうああ これは山登りも気持ちいいやと言いながら針の山を登った
登って上行ったところでもう極楽堂あるんだと
それで言ったら 閻魔様はこの人地獄に落ちちゃったらみんなの迷惑だから
そのまま行ってくれで行かせたんだと
そのストーリーで何言ってるんですかと
我々何かこのいい加減に南無阿弥陀仏とかって
結局気が弱いんですね
人々っていうのは だからしっかり生きてる人は天国に行くんだっていう話ですよ
あのおばあちゃんがもう歯を抜いたっても泣かなかったし
笑ったし 閻魔さんにもいろいろ脅かしちゃうとまた笑っちゃったし
鬼を見て怖がっちゃうんじゃなくて
あなた方も結構かっこいい男ではないかとかね
いいことしか見なかったんですね
地獄は嫌だと思って怖がらなかったし
今心の整理 順序を言ってるんですね
ですから 明るく生きていれば
もう我々の将来も確実に明るくなるんです
ということで それ仏教の道なんです
じゃあ それから悟りってなんですかと
もう私はわざわざとこの悟りのことを説明できないように時間延ばしたんです
別にそこを話すことになっちゃうと
なかなかもうややこしくて
だから他のお話をして
できるだけ時間延ばそうと
まあそこで結論として
この日々明るく充実感があって
何も悪いことをこの義理とおたっぽを持って悪いことをしないで生活することは幸福論であると覚えておいてください
それから毎日瞬間瞬間
我々は何を得られるんですか
充実感を味わう人生をする
それから毒のように捨てるのは何ですかというと
小欲 知性を守って そちらの反対の欲をちょっと欲を出すことだけはやめると
そうすると安静な人生ができるんだと
別に拝まなくてもいいんです
お数珠とかなんとか まあなくてもいいんですけど
別にお数珠なんかつけてると別に僕らは気持ちいいんですよ
なぜならば 仏教に興味ある人やというふうに思っちゃいますからね
ですから 私個人から言えば
十字架のペンダントを持っているよりは
小さな可愛いお数珠を持っている人にとっては
なんとなく愛情が生まれるんです
自分たちの仲間だから
まあそれぐらい得はあるかもしれませんだけど
まあだからといって 別にもうそういうことで
まあそこを守ってください
そうすると確実に幸福は得られる
お釈迦様の特色っていうのは
この得られないものは言わないんです
ここを一応論理的でも人間には幸福には味わえるということがわかるでしょ
それから論理的にわかるでしょ
こういうこの経済競争で
この必死になってこの戦って文明を発達しても
なんかドミノみたいに倒れるんだと
ちょっとしたことで それもわかるでしょ
ですから それじゃなくて
心に心の中に問題があると
そのストーリーはもうお分かりです
それで悟りのことに入ります
悟りというものも得られるんだからおっしゃってるんです
今の幸福論と同じ この悟りというのは
このないと人間の苦しみには終わりがないんです
このエネルギーというのはもう消えませんし
どう潰しちゃっても違う形取っちゃいますから
エネルギーは物質もそうでしょうに
宇宙は全部破壊して消えちゃっても
真空状態になっても そこにまたエネルギーは真空状態にあるんだから
またそれを使用 生まれてきて
また宇宙が現れる そこでまた破壊してまた現れる
で 心っていうのは一つのこの思考の回転なんですね
我々の心見ていると 一つ考えて終わると次のことを考える
それ考えて終わると次のことを考える
いつでも終わりがないんですね
終わらないんです じゃあ試しに皆様にチャレンジします
1 秒間の 100 分の 1ぐらい時間心止まってみてください
1 秒間要りません  1 秒間の 100 分の 1ぐらいでいいんです
見ること 聞くこと 感じること
考えること ちょっと止まってみてください
できますか？できないです
これは絶対できないんです
心っていうのは 一つ終わると次のことをする
それをやると次のことをする
そういう心が死ぬ時に終わりますよというと
それはちょっとした頭の知識がない人だけ言うのであって
死ぬと次のことをしちゃしまうんです
エネルギーは消えませんから
そういうことで 我々は亡くなってもまたどこかで現れちゃうんです
今 人間で立派でいるかもしれません
次には牛になるかもしれませんし
犬になるかもしれませんし
猫になるかもしれません
ミミズになるかもしれません
わかりません 生命はとにかく展開する
だからといって 別に魂霊魂があるわけでもないし
で なぜ我々は死んでもまた生まれ変わるのは楽しい
もしあったなら 生まれ変われるならば
どう思いますか？なんかまあ
信じる人も信じない人もいますけど
生まれ変わり信じたまにいるんですよ
あ 生まれ変わるんだ だから良かったと思う人がいるんです
でも仏教ではそれは良かったわけじゃないと
どこに生まれ変わるのかわからないでしょうに
もしも 他の 例えば犬になったらどうするんですかね
じゃあカエルになったらどうするんですかね
楽しいわけないでしょうに
地獄に生まれ変わったらどうするんですか？ですから
もう本当にわからないんです
例えば人間で生まれ変わっても
もしそのお母さんがちょっとした足が滑っちゃって
自分の体に障害入っちゃったらどうするんですか？障害で生まれたらどうするんですか？すごい恐れがあるでしょ
この胎児の時は障害で生まれるとそれって結構あるんです
あるいは自分がすごい不幸なところで生まれたらどうするんですか？あるいは自分が産んだ母親
この子はいりませんが
捨てて行っちゃったらどうするんですか？そんなこともありますからね
ですから 生まれ変わるのはもう事実だそうですが
いいことではありません
それは 恐ろしいことで
でも生まれ変わる それどういうことかというと
人間というのは無知だから
いくら頑張って苦労して生きていても
この小欲知足がないんです
ああ もっと生きていきたいんだと
大体生きていきたいのに死んじゃうんです
死にたくないのに死んじゃうんです
やむを得ず死ぬんです
がんになって もうあっちこっち体切って
もうどうしようもない
もうこれ以上進めない
でもこちらは 1 分でも生きていきたいと頑張ってますけど
もうどうしようもなくゲームオーバーになって死ぬんです
ですから ああ これから死にますよと明るく死ぬ人は一人もいない
なんかいくら生きてきたっても
もっと生きていきたいという欲があるんですね
ですから もうまた じゃあもう一回トライアルしてくださいと
あのゲームの場合も同じなんですよ
例えば ゲームセンターに行ってゲームをすると
そこですぐゲームオーバーになっちゃうでしょ
なんか悔しいんですね
もう一回やりたくなっちゃう
それでお金出してまたやると
それでまたゲームオーバーでしょ
また悔しいんです また 100円入れちゃう
それでお金ある限り入れてもうバカになっちゃうんですね
人生っていうのは 私はいつもゲームに例えますから
またその似てるんですね
ゲームオーバーなっちゃうんだけど
悔しいんです それでこの世で言ったら行いありますから
その行いはお金なんですね
それを使ってもう一回人生のゲームに耐えるする
トライする そこでまた負けちゃいます
また悔しい またもう一回トライすると
そういう風に続けてるんです
で そういう風に我々は生き続けている
そこで問題は それは危ないんだと
一回の人生でも大変苦しいし
終わりがない で 本当の心の納得はいかない
そこで究極的な安らぎで
究極的な落ち着きがあるんだと
それは解脱というんだと
輪廻転生はしない状態があるんだと
苦しみの終わりがあるんだと
それに解脱だというんだとお釈迦様はおっしゃってるんです
その状態は完璧に満足することからも生まれる
もう生きていてもう十分だと
あと一日でも生きていなくたってもいいんだと
そういう完璧な満足感生まれたら
もうその人は解脱してるんです
だから簡単でしょ やってみれば
なんか仏教のお坊さんたちの話を聞くと
もう相当無理な話なんだよ
解脱することは 悟ることは
だから 論理的に言えば完璧に満足得られれば完璧な満足を
今の人生について その人はもう解脱なんです
ですから簡単にチャレンジしてみてください
今もうやっていることにも完璧に満足感得られてみますと
それできないというならば
もう一つ方法あるんです
完璧に諦める で 道なしがないんです
完璧に満足する そうすると解脱を得られる
それ無理だなと思っちゃったら
完璧に諦めてみる その 2つの道があるんです
それでどうやって完璧に諦めますかというと
この何やったって結局はやがて意味がないでしょう
全ては変化しちゃうし
いくら食べても年取るしね
いつでも言ってる言葉なんですけどね
健康 運動したっても病気になっちゃうし
子供にいくら愛情を注いで育てたっても
子供は独立しちゃうし
いくら我々は 100年経って 200年経ってこの文明を作っても
これは 1週間で原子爆弾を起こしちゃったら 1週間で消えてしまっちゃうし
何ですかね 一体このやってる仕事っていうのは
物事全部は無常で 何をやったっても不完全で不満で
せっかく結婚したんだけど
やっぱり結婚相手は不完全でしょ
いい加減でしょ 納得いかないでしょう
それは旦那さんのこと納得いかないんだもん
旦那さんも同じなんですね
奥さんのことで納得いってないんです
だからあっちこっちなんか顔出してみるんです
もっと他のいい人がいるんですかとか
そこはまた同じで 全部人生は同じ
もういくら頑張っても不満だらけで終わっちゃう
それ出したらとことん物事の無常であることを無我であること
不完全であることを体験して
完全にはならない なろうとはしない
すぐ 全てのものについて諦めを生まれてもらう
心から欲を捨てる 欲なろう欲なろうと欲も捨てる
欲になることはないんだから
頑張っても全て無常だから
その方法はちゃんとあるんです
で そこで実践的なのは
完璧に満足することではないんです
完璧に満足することは論理的に正しいんだけど
不可能なんです でも 完璧に諦めることは論理的には実践的には可能なんです
毎日諦めてるんだからね
いろんなことを それは徹底的に諦めればそれだけのこと
それでお釈迦様はその道がおっしゃっているんです
それは暗く聞こえるかもしれませんよ
完璧に諦めるということは
でも不思議なこと 諦めると諦めるたびに楽しいんです
捕まって離せません 離せませんと言うと苦しいんです
例えば自分の子供にしても
あなたは私は愛情を持って育てた子供だから
あなたが帰ったら寂しいんだから
うちにいてちょうだいと言っちゃうと
子供にとってはものすごい嫌な母親で
もう家むちゃくちゃにしちゃうんですね
そうじゃなくて 小さい時からもうどうそうこちらに関係ないんだから
あなたは勝手にやってくださいと
私は一応大きくしてあげるだけですよと
言うと いつでも甘えてくるんで
お母ちゃんああだこうだとか
年取っても それでそれでお母さんね
この間ですねとか 大人らしく喋ってくれるし
だから離れたらなんかすごく楽で楽しいんです
自分の家を火事になったら
とにかくもう思い出のものやら何でもとにかく救済し
救出 なんて言いますか
もう取り戻そうとしようと思っちゃうとすごい苦しいでしょ
火事か まあいいやと思ったらすごい楽なんです
まあとりあえず全部燃えてるんだからまあいいんだと
そうすると思い出の品物あったならば苦しいんです
後でね 自分が他のところに
これは前の家の火事になったことを思い出しちゃうでしょ
それ綺麗さっぱり思い出まで燃やしてもらっちゃった方が気持ち楽なんです
皆様いろいろ皆様はもうそんなことないと思いますけど
例えばあるでしょ 家族の問題で離婚したりとかいろいろありますね
みんな精神的に苦しみ味わっちゃうんですね
なぜかというと 綺麗さっぱり忘れられないんですね
また思い出しちゃう それ苦しいでしょ
やっぱり今まで一緒に生きてた人だから思い出したりするわ
やっぱりああすればよかった
こうすればよかったではないかと思っちゃうわ
せっかく離婚したんだから
まあ元気でやってほしいなのに
暗くなっちゃうんです
それは諦めないんだからなんです
自分が年目で離婚しても
それで一年経って会ったら
あなた何さんですかね
ああそう じゃあというふうに
なんか初めて会ったような感じで
なんか全く知らないような感じですればいいんです
もう綺麗に忘れると 忘れるというのは
思い出は別に消えるわけじゃないんです
物事は私も綺麗に忘れてますけど
だからと言って思い出したければ思い出せます
でも執着はなし この間こういうことがあったよと
と それだけで明るく思い出す
ですから この諦めることっていうのは暗くないんです
諦めると楽しい 諦めると楽しい
そこで全ては究極的に諦めると究極に楽しく解脱というものを体験できるんです
それは人生の最終的な目的
それ以上人間には得るものは何もない
それ道なんですね 仏教というのは
じゃあ話はここら辺で終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます